hello everybody and welcome to part
three of penumbra overture all right we
left off just a giant spider I touched a
tongue I'm not sure what happened a lot
of stuff went down I don't know oh wait
this is where I been okay never going
back
haha you didn't see a thing so far
nothing scary happened I don't know
what's going on but definitely not scary
coming ah who's there who's there
butcha blood nobody oh hello yeah not
that uh you'd go anywhere near it but I
will come here come here
get in there who's there no one that's
right
OOP jerky
oh my jerky yeah all right I think that
was everything okay oh yeah I get the
lighter don't know what the letters for
but whatever all right bring it on yeah
dead doggie out here not for long comer
hum error
yeah back string no not quite right ah
shut up don't judge me
light it up light on fire shut up I'm
thinking straight
unlike you dude
Oh what am i no say no to do list found
a locked door interested the cable Oh
fantastic
thank you so much
whole room is putrifying good word good
word right uh nope nope nope ah yeah no
chair helped me before but now you're
being a problem yeah yeah yep yep yeah
yep
okay going in circles again yeah I'm
just milking this for time I just want
to make this as long as possible that's
how I do things
uh not quite thinking straight
flare painkiller okey Oh okey what do we
use a key key key key key key key key
yeah so smart nope oh [ __ ] you f you man
f you into a being so boring
oh wait am i and I really that stupid
am i that stupid don't answer that but
am I don't say it a word
yeah all right that's fine it is not
connected fine whatever
I believe you okay come on no no no no
no yeah okay yeah I'm great yeah oh yeah
this is gonna be a problem for you uh-uh
you're the dog the dog you do that why
did you do that dog
Oh baby Oh back here okay all right I'm
up block you up good this time I'm not
even gonna try it got here dog get out
of here yeah ah ah get out here okay
yeah yeah that one rock don't do it
I'm so great
hiding place not that I need it just
thinking about it
nope uh yep yep yep Red Seal four two
one four eight got it
Oh backwards okay backwards 8 4 1 2 a 4
1 2 a 4 1 2 if we 1 2 8 4 1 2 home again
ha ha yeah don't block [ __ ] 8 4 1 2 8 4
a 1 2 - oh so smart
oh look at me how smart I am
oh yeah you're all jealous jealous you
lucky I'm playing this you watch someone
else it gets stuck in the first level
for like 15 minutes
wouldn't that be stupid under these
rocks I was already doing it before I
read that oh yeah oh yeah gimme that
oh yeah pickaxe yeah oh yeah bring it on
dog I got [ __ ] on this ooh
gallery oh shut up uh-huh experimenting
have a heart attack
yeah you will oh my heart's like 10
heart unit strong I don't know shut up
don't judge me yeah yeah there we go oh
hello oh is that oh I can break this yar
yeah there we go
so awesome gimme ah no come come back
here get nariyal box oh yeah yeah that's
pirouette alright so far a whole lot up
I can tell danger when I see it but I
laugh in the face of danger
hahaha right fine
oh how about a box will that work yeah
box dancing box over here you're needed
and don't be dancing BAM oh yeah
diligent highly highly so oh wow wow hey
what the hell uh a plank of wood maybe
maybe yeah here give me give me some
okay pick it up
aha yeah I knew it
ah boom okay sorry about this [ __ ]
throw everybody boom yep yep oh oh yeah
oh so smart all right come here
ha nope ah yeah oh yeah ah no come on
you're embarrassing me go get this right
I'm gonna get it right shut up too far
away my arms are like ten miles long
yar almost almost
ah ah ah oh you're gonna yeah and then
you're gonna I'll shut up yeah yeah yeah
tip over ah ah dere gay
Oh God melodramatic there we go alright
let's see this right stupid board I
don't like you but have forced to work
with you ah don't be tipping don't you
be tipping you other board here go yeah
yeah well this isn't even the right way
at probably ah ha ha
kill me why Oh screw it
ah man get under dere and you get over
dere ah I'm gonna kill you board ours is
even the right way ah probably not
probably being stupid
ah okay I'm gonna give this one more try
I'm gonna look for another box could
maybe give me something yeah oh yeah
that was it calm calm calm I'm all
better now
ah a barrel a barrel fantastic
ah but oh don't even mess with me barrel
I'm not even in the mood I'm not in the
mood barrel no oh no oh I'm gonna roll
uh oh I'm gonna kill myself I'm gonna
kill myself
Oh myself I'm gonna kill myself
oh so mad so mad
and don't think this is because I'm not
smart because I am I'm so smart so so
smart just just had a lapse of smartness
momentarily Oh tip over Oh tip over tip
over tip over there we all right Oh Bob
I bet this is exciting to watch me
failing all over the place all over the
place all right
one's enough one did enough you greedy
barrel oh ah why don't you move
aah move aah oh no no girls that one I'm
gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] aah all right screw
it screw it screw it screw it screw this
screw this is dumb it's dumb for being
there yeah I've had it up to here I
can't even see where I'm pointing but
I'm pointing way up all right I got a
positive those aggravating oh I'm so mad
huh I'm not at you
thanks for watching thanks so much for
watching and stick around for part four
of let's play penumbra overture I'll get
over the stupid puzzle
ba-bye